[Music]
all right derek
derek oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh i was born in
toledo ohio is where i was born and
you're raised
uh in between toledo and detroit area
tell me about your family growing up you
had mom and dad yep uh my mom is dead
now she died about 10 years ago and
but i grew up uh
went to catholic school for 12 years um
was a
really competitive wrestler played a lot
of sports
i had a good family had a good mom and
dad
i'm 45 i was born in
76 so i grew up in 80s
was probably the last generation with uh
[Music]
no um
[Music]
internet stuff like that right now so
but your childhood was good no crazy no
no no crazy traumatic incidents or
anything like that
and you went to high school yeah yeah
after that yeah i graduated high school
yeah and
soon after that i just
immediately after that i had two
children
that are i think they're 25 and 26 now
they're a week less than a year apart
did you raise them uh
i paid child support
their mother raised them for a couple
years and then the state took them from
her and gave them to my mother
and father so
i was around but they were raised
basically by my mother and father i paid
child support and
i wasn't a great dad but yeah i paid my
child support
that's my claim to fame right can you uh
you've had jobs before
yeah i've had a lot of jobs yeah i can
hold the job
but
like today you're living a very
different lifestyle yeah you have in the
past i take it yep
tell me about how you live today
um
i just travel from place to place and
i hitchhike wherever i go i usually i
don't take too many buses or anything i
i hitchhike and
i do a lot of pacific crest trailing and
just a lot of san gabriel mountain
trailing out of l.a and
uh
i spend a lot of time
doing that these days i go to oregon i
spend a lot of time in oregon hiking
those mountains and
uh
but uh you stay on the west coast
yeah i always stay usually on the west
coast sometimes i go to like quartzite
arizona or i did that like a couple
years ago or um
[Music]
slab city or something like that you
know i go places like
tahoe
mount shasta i do that every year now
and and you walk most of it i walk most
of it or uh i when i'm trailing and uh
when i'm not catching a ride i i don't
stand still in hitchhike i actually
that's like the term hitchhiking it kind
of in terms you're or
[Music]
hitching and hiking
otherwise you're maybe just hitching but
uh yeah so like if you don't get
anywhere if you don't get a ride you
make can make 20 miles you know
how many miles do you walk in a day you
think um
always
20 but like i said we were talking
before sometimes i did four 30 mile days
last year
and uh
you could check out my youtube too
uh have you ever trained hop stuff like
that uh yeah i've hopped a couple trains
but i'm not big on it especially with
the dogs
uh i've done a couple easy hops
but
that's not really my thing train writing
isn't really my thing it's more
hitchhiking so what attracted you to
this this vagabond lifestyle um
what would you call yourself are you a
drifter are you a vagabond what are you
yeah them are both good terms i just a
traveler or whatever
[Music]
i don't know i never really fit in with
the
regular society i've never had a credit
card i've never had a car note i've
never had a
uh
a mortgage you know i've never had
like
like i don't know i just never really
bought into it into a society i still
don't
and i just i've never been happier than
doing this you know hence the face
tattoos yeah right right
that'll stop you from getting a job like
why did you do that it was like
it makes people it keeps people away
from me but really it doesn't it's like
a magnet it works like the opposite is
like it drew you
yeah yeah well that was part of it it's
probably more the dogs than anything the
whole like you said yeah what do i do
now now i put dogs on my back and
you'll see that later or whatever yeah
so you you'll see like i saw you in
santa monica and you're
you're out with your sign and you how
much money will you
collect in a day of doing that um
i mean there's a limited time in window
i can do it i have to have shade
and
i'm
with your back it i can only do that
maybe
three hours a day at max and then the
dogs only want to work two or three
hours a day so i have a window but i can
usually bring in like
on a weekend like maybe a hundred
dollars you know it's like
and that that works first because we
don't have any bad habits so
yeah so drugs are part of your life or
no no no i'd smoke pot but i mean in my
lifestyle you just get that for free
people just give it to you like on the
road i mean in my pack i probably got
close to a pound of wheat
in my pack
it's legal now so yeah it's illegal but
the harder drugs are something you've
ever played with or no yeah yeah i used
to in the 90s
and in the early 2000s still a little
bit was uh drinking and stuff but i used
to smoke a lot of crack after i was
drinking and
i used to go to jail a lot i've been to
prison a couple times all stemming from
drugs and alcohol
was alcohol the
the beginning of it yeah alcohol was
definitely the
the uh the main factor and
since i quit drinking i mean i've been
in california 10 years and i've never
been arrested
and
came close a few times but
it could have something a fact to do or
something to do with the fact that uh
california is not quite like a police
state like ohio and michigan either so
what and what does your family think of
of your lifestyle um
well my mother never got to see it
because it this really started when my
mother died
so yeah it's like
and because then my dad like got a new
life right away almost with a new wife
and then kids younger than my kids you
know step kids younger than my kids so
it was like
she was kind of the glue and then the
family like fell apart after that like
my kids are doing their own things now
you know have their own family my
daughter my son is struggling you know
uh i think
like i did but my daughter is a
graduate of cincinnati she went on a
full scholarship and she is a nurse and
has a kid and two dogs and a husband
who's a nurse and a house and a car and
all that stuff she fully bought in so
yeah so what do you where do you think
you get this
this inclination
is it and you it's just in your dna
i think so yeah i mean was there someone
you saw that was doing this and you said
i want to do that
i
you know what to tell you the truth i
can remember being
17 and 18 and
and
getting into some trouble and i remember
i remember thinking when i was 17 and 18
contemplating ways in my head before i
ever had kids or anything it was
contemplating ways in my head like how i
could live in these abandoned buildings
near
that area and like and like how i could
survive and then be warm and it's like
i've always had these like things in my
head now it's more like in the woods and
you know and and uh
i mean i've built cabins and like i've
done a lot i mean i'm a serious serious
hiker i've done a lot of hiking and
so you'll i document most of it oh you
do yeah yeah yeah i have like a bunch of
uh pacific crest trail and and uh
and um appalachian trail
and uh a bunch of other stuff i have a
uh a youtube and a facebook and a
facebook that i document everything on
really so you've been all over the
country
yeah yeah i have been i've been all over
the country but i like it here the best
i keep coming i it's better in
california than anywhere
do you have any regrets
um
[Music]
you know not really not
not not not too much i mean i don't wake
up every day and i was like man i wish i
didn't check i didn't do that or i wish
i didn't do this no i mean
i i like who i am and what i do i really
do i like the lifestyle that i live and
i'm happier than i've ever been and
conforming is just not for you no
i mean it takes all kinds right i used
to think people just think want
everybody to be like them like get a job
and this and that and it's like
everybody can't be like everybody it
takes all different kinds it takes a
whole spectrum you know it's like and
you're not hurting anybody to make the
world go round no i i try not to no i
mean
seriously i try not to i try to be a
good person and have good karma
you you support yourself by panhandling
yeah yeah and nothing else there's no um
i for the last three years i wasn't even
getting food stamps but when i was just
in the san francisco area they have
really good services and stuff on the
like the haight ashbury areas where i
hang out the hippie area
grateful dead area and hate ashbury and
uh they have really good services there
and uh um
they'll help you get your food stamps
and everything you know it's like not
even having to go like downtown because
i'm not good that's why i don't do that
stuff i'm not good with dealing with
like people and stuff but they'll come
out right there on the street and do it
on their phones for you like the the um
what would you call the outreach workers
and stuff yeah san francisco is really
good and my outreach worker was sasuke
shout out to south korea she's helped a
lot of people
and
um
do you have friends
uh yeah yeah i do i have uh
most of them in san francisco
uh and i have traveling friends that are
like
um
[Music]
all over the place but it seems like san
francisco is the main hub like venice
used to be a little bit but san
francisco the height ashbury area right
by golden gate park right there that's
the main hub for
travelers now
where everybody goes there that's where
all the travelers main hub
is is it the lack of responsibility that
uh appeals to you with this lifestyle um
that's definitely part of it and the uh
you're not paying any bills you're not
going exactly i used to stress a lot i'm
a stressor and i know people stress and
it kills you and i you can i you don't
realize that when you're younger when
you get older you can actually feel it
and see it killing you and yeah i don't
like the responsibility i like the uh
the being stress-free and i like to like
some days i'm just like i can just get
mad or somebody say something to me and
you know and
or
something just happened you know i mean
because people say mean stuff to you i
mean
it's okay i'm tough i can take it but
still do you get treated badly but
sometimes yeah i mean what's the worst i
try not to let people treat me badly
though you know i try to uh stick up for
myself and others what's the worst thing
that's happened to you um
well i'll tell you a story like stuff
like this i just
people see me and they see
like
the at the
average but i was in las vegas and i
used to work outside the paris or the uh
the mgm which is across the street from
like the paris not far and doing my dog
thing and so every morning i'd go into
the paris and use the bathroom and some
days i would i don't really gamble or
anything like i said i don't have any
bad habits but some days i would be feel
bad just for going in there and using
the bathroom so i'd play like a
a slot or something like a dollar's
worth of slots or a spin so one morning
i had i went in there and i would change
my change too and get and get cash work
because people give me a lot of change
so i went in there with like 40 worth of
change one day and
i cashed it went in there you know so
all these cameras are watching you as
you go in and i cashed the 40 worth of
change first and got 40
and then went up to the roulette table
and put 10 on black and lost it and then
put 10 more on black and got it back so
broke even and then walked over to the
uh slot machines and started playing the
slot and i'll play a couple of spins on
one and then take the receipt out and
then move to the next one then take the
receipt out move to the next one you
know play like few spins on each one and
so i'm doing that and i got the uh dog
with me and
a guy comes i'm dressed kind of like
this but like overalls like the sound
but they looked worse they had used to
have patches all over them and stuff guy
walks up to me and says i'm gonna have
to ask you to leave like a security guy
like undercover security guy and i'm
like i'm like well this is my service
animal i was like but i'll leave you one
he's like that's not why he's like we've
seen you taking receipts out of machines
and i was like yeah you did because
they're my [ __ ] receipts i was like i
i was like did you you must have seen me
changing forty dollars worth of you know
uh
a change and did you see me playing uh
uh ten dollar spins on the roulette
wheel two ten dollar spins and it's like
people just see what they wanna see and
people see you steal stuff that you
didn't steal or take something that and
people swear with their that's what i'm
saying and this guy has everything on
camera you know and he's like do you
even get an apology for that no but if i
was a yuppie i would have been eating
for free i would have been gambling for
free my room would have been calm but
they would never make that mistake with
somebody that was
did you have the face tattoos then uh i
had the
like the skull one
the the other is not yeah see the face
tattoo is freaky but i still had a lot
of
tattoos you know but
it's like yeah people like that's when i
learned to like cops and security and
stuff people think like they watch tv
and stuff and think all this stuff is
like so high-tech and like these people
like yes um technology is high tech but
the people using it are clowns usually
you know it's like
they are
not everybody but it's like it's like
that for everything there's a bun in any
business and anything there's clowns and
there's professionals you know like when
even what i do there's clowns and
there's people like me that are
professionals you know it's like
some people just get five dollars and go
buy a hit of [ __ ] meth you know not
me dude i'm staying for the get what i
need you know it's like and i'm not
going to spend it on meth and
i'm going to get what i need
so what are you afraid of what do you
worry about um losing my dogs
that's really the one thing that's
the biggest thing i worry about or
getting hurt
and having to take like a hospital trip
or something and
because i can't go to the hospital yeah
your life comes apart with dogs exactly
you know so i try to be really careful
are you lonely
um
not not too much no it's like
i when you're younger you're chasing
women around and stuff like that like i
said i'm 45 so i come to the point in my
life now i'm really happy with myself
it's like
i couldn't even be with a woman unless
it was somebody that's not gonna be on
my nerves in five minutes you know
somebody that i could talk to it's like
as you get older things just change but
i'm not
i'm not lonely are you are you you're
you seem happy i am i am genuinely um
you're just living a very alternative
lifestyle right yeah i'm doing what i
want to do for sure it's like
it doesn't take a lot of money to do
what i want to do it's it
and walking
makes me happy it's the one thing that
makes me happy whether i'm road walking
or hitchhiking or
walking on trails it's
just moving around from place to place
and meeting people and
and
and uh
people always say man i wish i did what
you did i wish i could do that you know
and it's like and it keeps me going it's
like people always say keep going and
it's like now i don't want to quit i
just want to do more and more and it's
like i've even done like uh
i've got documented too like on my
channels and stuff i did uh
i've rode a bike with a trailer with a
dog from la to san francisco and then
i've done it on uh when the coven first
started i bought a three-wheeled bike a
trike office a guy
and i rode that trike all the way
past san francisco
all the way to
um
fort bragg before it broke down a
three-wheeled bike and let me tell you
something you ain't meant to travel on a
three-wheel bike because on a
two-wheeled bike you're always straight
up and down no matter how the roads
curve on a three-wheeled bike you're
always leaning one way oh it's right
because because the road is curved yeah
and it's like it was hell it was a
five-speed or six-speed
like three-wheel bike and i was like
yeah
do you think some of the negative
reaction you get from from strangers
when you're on the street
is probably
they
resent your
your freedom and your you know your
you're such a non-conformist here you're
you're basically just living however you
want to live
and they may they might
react to how they have to conform
whether they even realize it or not yeah
i actually do think that it's funny that
you said that i had a guy that i went to
high school with
and
i was really good friends with him and
i'm not gonna say his name but he
he told me that he was like
he was like i love you but i was like i
don't know whether to resent you or he's
like sometimes i resent you he was like
because you just don't take any
responsibility and you're like you just
like live carefree and he's like at this
point in his life he has a lot of
responsibility with like coaching and
kids and family and you know and it's
like it's a lot of pressure that's a lot
of pressure it's a lot of responsibility
but there's something to be said for it
too i mean that has rewards
too yeah there's a trade-off for both
right it is that has rewards too
everything we do in life has a trade
that's right yeah
i mean ever
it's not for everybody ever
it takes all kinds
you have to figure out what works for
you that's right then you found
something that's fair i think this
worked for me yeah very very different
from most people's lives but and it's
not like i just went from this one day
like i said like my youtube can i say my
youtube or whatever sure go ahead it's
uh i usually don't but go ahead it's
deke brewer d-e-k-e-b-r-e-w-e-r
and my facebook is the same but it's
b-r-e-u-e-r i just spelled it two
different ways but uh anyways i won't
make a habit of that yeah anyways yeah
you can edit it out if you want but it
just shows the progression of you know i
didn't just end up like this one day i
didn't know anything about doing the dog
i just started hitchhiking and i was
living i was in chicago for a while like
michigan city if you know the area on
the south shore line living in
shelters and stuff you know and it was
like i made my way to portland and then
made my way to l.a and was like i was
clean at the time but i was like home
bum in it you know i was like really
down on my luck
and
one day
a tweaker gave me a dog i was watching
it for us she never showed back up to
get it it was a
and
i was playing ball with a dog then a few
days later and the ball went under the
car and i'm reaching under the car and
the dog started like jumping on my back
and a light bulb just went off it was
like man
i can do like a trick with the dog you
know and so i used to just get down and
read and the dog would just sit on my
back as i read you know before the
sunglasses or anything and i put my hat
down there one day and people started
dropping money in my hat and i was like
i made like 10 bucks and i was so happy
because i could get something to eat and
it wasn't broke and and then it
progressed from there like with the
sunglasses and you know
and things like that and
i've been doing it since
yeah and and about the youtube i mean i
don't even monetize or have any like
hits or that many followers or anything
so you know i don't i don't do any of
that i just do it for documentation so
do you have do you have is it difficult
for you to be on the street where you're
probably
lumped into the whole drug addict
homeless person
group even though you're not you're very
different from most of the people that
are living on the street yeah is it
difficult for you to being lumped into
that group um
it's you know it's not that bad because
i think most people want to like
homeless people and want to help
homeless people it's just that they get
so bad on drugs and they uh
people on methane uh
they have no boundaries and then they
don't care about themselves so that if
you don't if you hate yourself you don't
care about your garbage and the trail
and the mess you leave behind you know i
think they people wanna
like and help homeless people and i me i
try to make it easy for him you know i
try to give
a good name for people but it's like
it's
it is very few and far between i mean 99
of the people that are are in this
situation are on drugs are on meth i
mean the shit's everywhere
everywhere i mean it's not just homeless
people either it's people in houses and
cars and rich people and meth is
destroying our society
it's a really bad thing and and people
are going to keep using it i mean it's
never going to go away you got to give
people alternatives they not want to use
it you know to the to be happy in other
ways or not be miserable do you think
meth is a bigger problem than
heroin fentanyl crack anything like that
um
yeah i think it is because it's so
readily available and so [ __ ] cheap
people just give it to you
that's the problem you know and it's
like they're just handing you death and
people like oh i don't pay for drugs it
doesn't matter it's killing you you know
it's like
it's but then they sell alcohol in
grocery stores and yeah yeah i mean that
that's well here's the thing with that
it's like that's just as bad too but
it's a slow methodical death and even
with the the heroin and crack and stuff
people you can get off that [ __ ] and
still have your brain
and still have your your life and and a
little bit of sense about you the the
methamphetamine you see how these people
act on the methamphetamine it turns you
uh
uh i can't say that i'm not supposed to
say [ __ ] but it turns you uh
i call it methamphetamine induced
schizophrenia
and
it it uh there's psychosis they call it
psychosis yeah but it's methamphetamine
induced and it's like it's
lack of sleep too yeah yes and but that
doesn't go away they call it the new
meth now is what they're calling it and
that's what they call it the new meth
and
you can like uh they were just talking
about it on the radio about how quickly
now it deteriorates you and does
permanent brain damage to you and
it just
it's just bad everybody on it you see
they're just talking to themselves they
don't got no shoes on they uh
all these conspiracy theories they're
all disheveled they can't comb their
hair they can't brush their teeth you
know it's like
it's
they're up they're walking like zombies
it literally is turning you into a
zombie literally and
it's sad to look at it it is why why did
you uh put down the drugs
um it's been a long time right it's been
10 years i think so yeah i
i mean i always liked who i was i think
that's key is you gotta learn how to
love yourself if you can't learn to love
yourself
or even like yourself it's like and
that's where people are at i think it's
a i put it down because i've always
liked who i was and i battled all the
time like i never like i'd use and then
i would beat myself up and be like man i
can't be doing that you know i got i got
to do this so i got these
responsibilities and and it took it just
it takes sometimes people a while to
learn and
and some people never learn and some
people you know it's
again it takes all kinds some people
learn their lessons some people don't
some people go to jail some people die
um
some people are saved whatever you know
it's
but
i
i think the key is learning to love
yourself or learning finding something
in your life that you can live for or do
something even if it's not you for
something else for a dog even you know
it's like
it's
like
maybe if you just have a dog maybe then
you have to get up every morning you
know and and and
i don't know i don't know but
and i don't want to use drugs because i
feel bad when i do and then i feel like
you'll be feeling like you're letting
the dogs down you know or anything i i
can't even get myself to do acid or
anything anymore when everybody else is
doing it because then the next day i'm
like what am i doing with my life you
know it's like what the hell
and
i just
i don't even want to use you i mean
you'll get to the point
i think i tell most people to where
you'll either die or you'll get to the
point where you just you don't want to
use drugs anymore
and
[Music]
i mean everybody comes to a crossroads
at some time you know and
[Music]
we all make decisions and
but i want to be on this earth to me
this is a big game and the longer you
can stay on this earth
is the the more you're winning the game
you know it's like so to win the game
you got to be here forever so i'm trying
to be here forever
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
wow that's a tough one um
probably that
to work hard for whatever you want you
can get it
but
you can't do it by yourself yeah every
it takes you know it takes it's going to
take help from can't do it by yourself
even though i like to be independent and
try to do everything by myself i can't
make my own clothes and hunt my own meat
you know it's like even indians couldn't
do that they had a whole tribe you know
right
and so
that and i think uh
i used to have no compassion for anybody
or no
i still don't have a lot as much as i
should probably but i have more now like
i can look at people and
and
not so much feel sorry for them but like
empathize with them a little more and
like
it doesn't even matter if i if a
person's a drug addict or alcoholic or
not i'll still give them money or
something you know it's like i don't
care what they're gonna do with it it's
just sometimes i just see somebody and i
feel for him or you know the lady
standing on the corner and she's saying
dollar dollar dollar
because she wants some coffee or
something mcdonald's and everybody just
walks by her and doesn't give her no
money you know so
it's like i'll make a show out of that
like it's like you guys are gonna give
this lady five dollars or go get
something to eat so i will
but i try to be i try to be good to bums
i try to the ones that are even not the
ones that are so great all the time but
the ones that
are even you know there's some out there
that are using drugs that are released
they're good people they are but
there's a lot of people out there that
are good people but it even it'll take
everything from you and it'll even take
your nowadays the drugs will even take
your your almost takes your soul now to
where you're once you get to a certain
point you're not even a person hardly
anymore yeah your behavior becomes
so scandalous have you seen like zombies
out there that like i see some almost
every day that are just they're walking
like this because they can't walk
anymore and their feet are messed up and
they can't talk really anymore
i've interviewed a bunch of them no have
you yeah it's bad yeah you can really
communicate with them
yeah right right but they weren't always
like that no of course not
and that that makes me sad it does it
does
there has to be something there has to
be a breaking point something has to be
done about
about something and it's
i don't know it's a
the methamphetamine is bad it is it's
it's i think it stems like all the
problems
that
this city has you know they'll say the
homeless problems or the just all the
problems that this city has almost stems
from methamphetamine
that and the money grabs stealing all
the money
yeah but i think if you go a level
deeper there's
what you said earlier about liking
yourself or loving yourself yeah oh yeah
because you wouldn't be doing the drug
if you right right that's and that's
what i said though like the key is not
and then you go a level deeper then you
go they say well we got to get rid of
the drug dealers and the cartels well
they'll get rid of themselves if you
stop buying their drugs yeah but then
you go a level deeper and then it goes
it gets into parenting yeah and that's
what i'm saying if you stop buying their
drugs but in order to do that you have
to make the kids not want to buy them
drugs all these people that have been
using drugs already they're done already
they're done you might you have to start
with the kids that's where the key is
and they're not building like the city
the schools are all [ __ ] up the
teachers are all [ __ ] off you know
what i'm saying they're all just worried
about themselves and their unions
they're not teaching kids man and that's
and that's why the society is all [ __ ]
up is you gotta start with kids dude
it's too late for adults you gotta start
with little ass kids and teach them and
teach them right and and it's not even
about indoctrinating them it's about
giving them opportunities to do things
that don't involve drugs like yeah no
loving them and giving them good role
models yes yeah and giving them things
to do like you know boys and girls more
boys and girls clubs and better ones and
better facilities it's like you can
build all this [ __ ] for homeless people
and stuff where's all the facilities for
kids at with swimming pools and
playgrounds you know where you can and
drop in centers for poor kids not just
for rich kids for poor kids that can
just go to these places you know and
there's really not any and then they say
why are these what are these kids doing
drugs for you know it's because they
don't have anything else to do and like
you said role models and coaches and
and things like that man
all right derek thank you so much for uh
sharing your story
very interesting your dogs are so well
behaved yeah yeah yeah
my sunglasses look how well behaved that
dog is
you